this landscape may look idyllic but
something importance is missing there
are no large predators in mountain zebra
National Park which was established some
seventy years ago but that's about to
change
cheetahs will once again hunt these
grounds
[Music]
researcher Kelly Marnie wick is working
with two males that are being relocated
to the park named Batman and Robin the
dynamic duo will restore the parks
predator-prey balance while helping out
some of South Africa's wild game farmers
the volt wild cheetah project started in
the year 2000 as a result of conflict
experience between farmers and cheetahs
the phone was a price to build with hip
problems with cheetahs and Austin -
please come up with solutions to the
conflicts to better understand the
conflict researchers have been
monitoring the cheetahs movements by
outfitting the animals with a GPS cell
phone caller Kelly can follow their
routes on her computer and from this
website we can see where our cheetahs
are walking and where their being even
even when we couldn't find them or see
them regular updates show when a cheetah
trespasses on a farm and you can see
these brown lines here represent farm
boundaries and you can see how the easy
she's moving in and out of game fencing
[Music]
as a last resort when a cheetah causes
too much damage on a farm it must be
captured and relocated the problem
cheetahs get a thorough veterinarian
check-up once finished with the
preparations the team sets off across
country to the Cheetahs new home after
arriving at Mountain zebra National Park
the Rangers put Batman and Robin in an
enclosure called a boma here they
acclimatize to the local surroundings
and the locals acclimatize to them I
[Music]
have to say when we first brought them
here they arrived and we put them in the
boma we had a line of spring but lined
up on the other side because they didn't
really know what was going on and the
monkeys were cha-cha-cha-cha-cha they
know now that there's a predator in the
area after several months it's time to
release the Cheetahs into the park
the Rangers tempt Batman and Robin out
of their enclosure with a carcass but
this will be their last hand-fed meal
from now on they will hunt their own
prey
park rangers use radio powers to monitor
the cheetahs closely but within a few
days the cats slip into stealth mode and
go off the radar
[Music]
mix however some grisly remains suggest
the males are adapting well as for the
zebras and other game their idyllic life
may be over
but the picture of a healthy ecosystem
is looking more complete
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium